how do you do fellow kids it's me your
super cool hip Zoomer pal Michael
Knowles here with another installment of
gen Z vocabulary last time I think I did
pretty well I acquitted myself nicely by
knowing all the hip cool lingo 23 skidoo
and I'm gonna do it again baby I bet I'm
gonna get most of these right this is
brought to you by Jen you sell more from
them in just a little bit first though
let's start out with my Riz you know my
rizz Riz I've heard this word I think I
heard it on the whatever podcast Riz I
think is like it's like my game my
demeanor my my junise that that you know
is how people perceive me in the world
is that right another word for spitting
game yeah kid how good you are with with
pulling and sustaining many women that
was a little bit cheating because the
gals on the whatever show talked about
my Riz and also the Riz of the host of
that show and impaired the respective
Rises
and they found my wrist to be superior
I'm not saying that that that's just
what they happen to say so an example is
person one are you from Tennessee
because you're the only 10 I see person
watching from afar damn that simp has no
ribs that's true that would be a risless
sort of thing to say to a lady okay next
one touch grass this is pretty clear
this is a an imperative command that you
would make to somebody who has gone too
far down the virtual reality Rabbit Hole
they're two terminally online they need
to get out of their hyper Niche
abstracted Bizarro world and they need
to come back into contact with reality
they need to get back into the physical
tangible World grounded they gotta
literally touch grass okay definition
used when someone is doing something
weird stupid or pointless means they
need to come back to reality they need
to get some fresh air and get back into
with how the real world Works bam baby
baton a thousand example of this would
be been keeping track of my crush's snap
score snap score she's most active on
Friday least active on Monday most
dude you need to go touch grass get a
job or something damn so the only thing
I'm confused about there is a snap score
I hope that's not a phrase that comes up
late I don't know what a snap score is
an OP
okay and this is this is spelled OPP
which is confusing because if I were if
I were hearing about an OP like oh man
that's a total op for like man that
George Floyd stuff man what an OP that
was I would believe that that were a
political operation or a psy-off you
know it's it's a distraction and a
provocation
to create some kind of chaos or to
provoke and impel some kind of reaction
now my producers spelled it OPP
so there I'm going to say that maybe
that refers to some kind of opportunity
coming up or some other term that I'm
unaware of or it could just be the case
that my producers don't know how to
spell cool gen Z lingo so let's see
what's the definition
ah damn right now is wrong it's anyone
in a competition against you
so it's not a psyop and it's not an
opportunity it's an opponent okay that's
what I get from my hubris for thinking
that I knew how to spell these terms
better than my producers do an example
my mom
made me take out the trash while this
hottie was checking out my Minecraft mod
she was being a total op she was she was
and now you won't be able to spit that
Riz at the hottie checking out your
Minecraft mod a baddie
well I always think of Baddie as that
that British sketch of the Nazis you
know do you ever think oh we're the
baddies oh we the baddies so what's a
baddie I don't know I assume it's like a
bad b-i-t-c-h you know someone who's
really notorious
you know someone who maybe you don't
want to you don't want to bring home to
Mom but because of our concupiscence it
would be someone to whom we nevertheless
are attracted that would that's that's
how I would view Baddie is that close
let's see the definition a girl who is
hot ASF can be slim and thick but don't
have to be independent and can hold her
own yes I guess do I get credit for that
control room's gonna take a vote I think
because the definition just tried to put
Baddie in the best possible light thank
you they're going to give it to me and I
was I was describing Baddie in perhaps a
more realistic light and then the
example they gave is producer Justine is
a total Baddie hey come on now let's be
it's not nice maybe it is in a way it is
kind of nice but I think producer
Justine is a lovely lady who you very
much would like to take home to meet
your parents she's she's beautiful both
inside and out how about that
i y k y k this is obvious man will you
can you please challenge me can someone
who doesn't underestimate my hipness
please write these terms
if you know you know
and I know
for real for real No Cap
definition is of course if you know you
know it's usually associated with
sarcasm and eye winks
just put a pause right there
what other kind of Winks are there
like a nose Wing ear wink
a wink is a motion of your eye an
example Biden totally Biden totally won
the 2020 presidential election
#if you know you know now how do I stay
so vibrant and young one way would be
genucel our friends over Virginia cell
have you covered geniusell is offering
70 7-0 off their most popular package
which includes their Ultra retinol and
Dark Spot Corrector our producers love
the ultra retinol offered in genucel's
most popular package the nighttime
moisturizer contains a powerful retinol
alternative to visibly reduce the
appearance of Fine Lines wrinkles and
skin discoloration without the
irritation of retinol genucel's Ultra
retinol helps to exfoliate the skin
which can reduce the appearance of pores
and improve skin texture can even help
to even out that skin tone by reducing
the appearance of age spots and hyper
pigmentation best of all geniusl
guarantees results in as little as 12
hours or your money back plus I love the
whole company and I love the founder
great guy from Egypt Coptic Christian
fled Egypt for the American dream go to
geniusell.com Knowles YT
letter y letter T to save over 70 70 on
their most popular package that includes
the Dark Spot Corrector as well as their
Ultra retinol and under eye treatment
you will get a complimentary spy
Essentials box with every order plus a
free upgrade to priority shipping
geniusell.com Knowles YT genasell.com
knowlesyt back to the lingo
it's giving
is it a shortening of like it's giving
birth and then you say that in a kind of
ironic way or it's giving of itself
it's giving it's not even giving which I
said it's supposed to gay but I have to
have some kind of guess it's giving or
is it like is it is it a play on
Thanksgiving and it's sort of but it's
like a
I don't know definition depending on
context if someone says it's giving to
you and adds nothing after then that
means the person thinks you find ASL
they mean ASF you what is ASL they're
telling me ASL is as hell why wouldn't
that be as H that'd be Ash
also applies to other nouns looks good
if the person says it's a giving
and then adds something after then what
they say after is what they think of the
noun
they're talking about okay so the
example is girl one that boy over there
girl it's giving
girl too but his friend is giving
stalker Vibes so I don't know it's a
giving so I kind of like that because
what we're saying is that the uh default
term ought to be goodness
it's giving
Good Vibes right it's giving Pleasant
feelings it's giving Beauty I like that
that that's the default we're moving
away from the cynicism of the
millennials
and we're moving into
the frivolity though I think
perhaps um greater giddiness of the
Zoomers
next word t oh well that's obvious
tease that good gossip you know that's
that stuff you gotta spill what's the
tea there we go there we go man I'm so
cool I can't get oh even I am sometimes
impressed by my absolute vocabulary Riz
the best kind of Gossip they say
typically shared between friends it's a
bonding tool for people of all ages it's
also a mortal sin but go on at least if
you if you ascend with your will doing
to engaging and spilling that tea who
cries over spilled milk nobody but you
know who cries over spilled tea you if
you burn in hell for eternity because of
your sins T is usually about someone you
know but can also extend to celebrities
random internet scandals Etc examples uh
I've missed so much what's the T sis and
the answer is I don't know who wrote
these examples I heard producer Jacob is
single and into this conservative e-girl
still the t-bay I actually did I did
encounter some of that tea spilled on
the floor of the studios I've
encountered that a number of times next
word Bop it's like when you twist it and
you pull it and you bop it you know Bop
what is Bop it's not Bonk I've sometimes
seen Bonk in memes on Twitter which is
when people get a little too lecherous
in their commentary and people say Bonk
you've got to stop doing that but Bop
what is Bop is it a verb is it a noun
Bop the the whole point of lingo is to
elude uh people so the whole point of it
is for me to not be able to understand
it
and I think this one has reached that
level I don't Bob is it if I'm gonna say
just try to get half a point or
something it's some kind of physical
feature rather than say a verb or some
mere concept nope totally missed it uh
used to reference a good song
to say that a song is really good I like
that because it's kind of old-timey like
Bop you're gonna go to the sock hop and
listen to some Bops example Smokey Mike
and the god king just dropped a new
track it's such a Bop you know it every
time that's a big Bop
drip oh kid you think I don't know about
drip you think that I could walk in here
every day actually today my drip is a
little bit lacking because I keep
stealing my clothes and leaving them at
home and not bringing them back to
wardrobe but any person of Italian
extraction especially one with a very
nice wardrobe Department over here is
going to know what that good trip is kid
you know it's that fashion it's that
it's that demeanor it's that whole mode
of comportment definition they say is
very swag and cool drip drippy dripping
can be used to describe an outfit
accessory person a song
Etc and the example is have you seen
Michael Knowles's hair and olive skin he
must be using Jeremy's razor hair and
body products either way it's a total
drip thank you very much to whoever
wrote up that example
bussin oh man I know about bussing
because this also was introduced to me
on the whatever podcast but I think it I
think I kind of forgot it it's not when
you're capping is busting like when
you're joking
or
or I forgot what bus it looks when you
write it out it looks like it's French
like Busan what is it Busan blessing is
it like you're hustling like you're
working very hard I'm gonna say Bustin
has to do with work ethic just to throw
it I don't what do I do Busan
is an adjective used when something is
so good
that's it this stuff is buzzing
they don't have these lingo words just
mean good usually when people say
bussing and they're talking about food
example is it bus and Janelle that
s-h-i-t was bussing I just had to take
another bite of that he him or she her
chocolate bar is this whole exercise
merely a way to plug Jeremy's consumer
goods is that what this is about maybe
okay next one dank oh well that's like
the memes that I produce for example
would be extremely dank uh dank not
meaning
um fetid and moist and diseased but dank
meaning of superb quality like if I were
going to you know head on down and smoke
a little bit of that Haitian oregano you
know get some of that sticky icky I
would I would request that it be the
absolute dankest of the Dank not that I
would do that of course because I'm not
a huge lib and I prefer tobacco to the
devil's lettuce that's a discussion for
another time so you know in a way this
is another one of these words that just
means like very very good but in a way
that has a kind of mischievous and a
connotation and and also a connotation
of connoisseurship slang used from
something it wouldn't describing
something cool hot and totally awesome
yeah have you seen courageous that movie
is dang okay I think there are multiple
producers in that room who are writing
these examples so okay he's using the
example my producer Ben Davis is using
an example of a Christian movie that he
starred in I was describing that sticky
icky perhaps both are dang actually
perhaps it's just the former who knows
dead d-e-d I assume this is just a
Charming way of
spelling d-e-a-d like for instance if
you told me a joke or if you even better
insulted somebody in a way that was
really biting
I would then be dead I would be totally
dead from that it would have killed me
it would have killed us all
with its wit and cleverness is that
right sending each other memes until one
of the participants dies of laughter so
they are known as dead yup 100 I am a
young vibrant man much like the former
president said about himself I am way
cooler than I expected because all these
all these pop culture references you're
seeing here like modern things that the
kids do I don't know they play video
games and go to disc attacks and stuff I
don't really know anything about that as
far as the lingo goes man as far as the
words go I am there the example is LMAO
Ben and Jacob keeps sending me the
funniest memes on the internet I'm dead
I'm not sure I think I'm I when they
send me memes I usually ossify I'm dead
from rigidity because of how unfunny the
memes frequently are but either way I
guess it would be the same conclusion
the sauce
well the old-timey meaning of that lingo
would be booze it's like ah Old Uncle
McGillicuddy's on the sauce again but I
assume it doesn't mean that because
lingo changes the sauce it's not like
the tea
is it like the secret sauce like the hot
sauce like something to kind of spice
you up make you a little bit Saucier is
that that's what I'm gonna suggest when
you see a porn Meme and ask for the
origin
I'm glad I didn't know that I'm I'm
proud to say I did not know that example
yo bro
what's the sauce for this asking for a
friend why is it called sauce oh like
the source says my obviously pornography
addicted man in my ear right now who is
so aware of this like this give me the
sauce like you're from Boston or
something
[Music]
I kind of like it again Pick Me Girl
is a pick me girl the image I have in my
head when I hear that I've never heard
that before is of a girl in ninth grade
English class just saying pick me I've
got like a kiss up or something like a
goody two shoes like a teacher's pet and
so I I could see the phrase applied not
merely to the academic setting but even
to social settings I could see it even
applied to the kind of girl who's vying
for the attention of men who's just gosh
very ostentatious and demanding
attention is that right yeah there we go
pick me girl is a girl who seeks male
validation by indirectly or directly
insinuating that she is not like the
other girls
it's basically a female version of a Sim
yeah those girls I'm I I I'm not like
the other girls you know I'm a cool girl
girls who say oh I I'm only friends with
the boys I don't I'm not friends with
girls okay well maybe you should be
friends why is why is that other than
the fact that women just as a general
rule all hate each other but again
that's also a topic for another time the
example here is Natalie just loves
Andrew Tate
she's such a picnic girl that's true
it's where a gal would disingenuously
pretend to agree with something a man
thinks in believing mistakenly that a
man wants someone in a romantic partner
who is identical to him rather than
complementary to him but uh also in the
mistaken view that when a man says
something and when a woman says say
something that that's the same but
they're not the same because men and
women of course are different okay
what's my favorite one I would say my
favorite one is probably
Bop
I like Bop because it's just so
wholesome it shows you how
lingo and faddish language is recursive
that history doesn't repeat but it does
Rhyme that that actually our language is
is a commentary on itself you see this
process of language all the time I think
about
beads beads bees beads beads job's not
on board you know I I pray a rosary and
the rosary is beads other there are
other types of rare beads that you can
pray as well and the beads refer to the
word bid like I bid like I pray you to
do something so the the word for bead
which we now use beads in all sorts of
ways comes from the prayer beads that
refer to the prayers and so you you see
this constant deepening of meaning the
further back you look throughout our
language from language that is now
rather conscious and critical all the
way back to that early language which
was so dense with meaning and so so uh
poetic you see all these layers how can
I bring this to Earth a little bit the
word rad
in the 80s the word rad was really cool
in hip and lingo and then rad went away
and it was extremely lame and not cool
at all and then rad kind of came back
but in a sort of ironic way where you
would but but the thing about irony is
that if you engage in irony all the time
then it's no longer ironic it becomes
Earnest I love that Bop my
least favorite one sauce it's so
degenerate not just to look at porn
which is ubiquitous but to go further to
say okay you there's porn everywhere and
then people are making jokes about porn
and you're laughing about the joke about
the porn but you're so addicted to this
smut that you then in the midst of your
joke you cut off your laughter to try to
get the porn itself to go back and
take it very seriously yuck now my
producers are trying to wiggle their way
out of this porn Thing by they're saying
no it doesn't have to be a porn thing
all right I think I think we all know
where you've picked up your gen Z lingo
fellas in the control room yuck you're
not going to have very much Riz if you
keep up that kind of behavior
enough of that disgusting
[Music]